у цих початкових заходах зараза не
траплялося по університетах
нехай це студенти надзвичайно ми
розуміємо ще за донбасом
завищується в украй стабільну і тугішу
для контролю ванну та на та відсіку вона та
кошу під у собі статус точно то в
луганську та області розкрити початковий
рік 13 вищих початкових закладів у
структурних петрова стилі воду на етиці
давайте очистити не відчинити початкові
луганській області тридцять три вищі
початкові заклади структурних
підрозділів у донатики 75 так-то
дрогобич 6 вищих початково закладі на
донбасі на рус потягнути за раз
початковий рік відразу кольору і наука була
підготовлена ​​розпорядилися чудо того що
корінних при початкових закладемо на
донбасі моїх праву самі за поведінкою з
міністерством позначають і термін
початку початкову уроку
що випадково буду заклади, то вид військовий
ситуації у районі
у розпорядженні також регульована
харчування перекладами студенту золотому басу
передача та . студентів університету на
низьку ланську область будуть тими годинами
допускатися сяду наша мене фак 1000 ми
надрукуємо праску павутину на ревнивими
студентами
формального не раз продовжити через
ось якщо ви університеті в донецьку і
луганську та області та зв'язок лікування
самобуд і я купу університету всіх
областях видно вулиць свою роботу
студентам буду за проб оного на них
нею виберу а база лиж і тис авт їх
університету в будиночках їх переведено обидва
повернутий і вся в Донецьк луганськ речами
статті про регіон звучить
складна ситуація якої миколи ніхто нам
of справа і тут рішення трах прямо ти
повинен озвучені часто
за натискаю на мисі правового поля
у нас тільки ви спочатку закладок
пройде 4 години про дотації 166 тисяч
туди інте вселяються
саду жував і крапелька секунду до 1000
перший інші ремінь акредитації та
вежа 215.000 студенти всього на донбасі
порушується вивчаємо на
просто всіх рвучко за раз блогу душі
складно там у нас по девайсу 1:13
ідентиф якщо від цього годинної пори року
немає кращих вищих нашої на закладі
листи укладання військових день на
донбасі захоче повернути ася в
університету донецької луганської області
наразі процедура тем чусової піраміди
не дозволяє нам переказ забарахлити і
університети
продай мені на і звірятка викладок і
тому що б ми повністю perwoll
абсолютно всіх студентів і по 1000 і по
ви не було б закриті всі ставкою по
точно дізнаємося цього скарбу
скільки ми поведе розуму від вивчаємо опитування
данте прохання спайку вони так вже мають рацію
кладаче тому що звір він це
заразне тільки тисяч ви кладовищем на
донбасі була б спрямована
страви на ви нафти ситуації у вас іншому
цьому за весну
за руслана мага і муся запуску рахунку
права та викладати зі студентів 1
поразка продуло міністр сума святі
ногу було прийнято на засіданні кабінету
міністрів у манаусі роду позавчора
за 1 знаходиться на підписі в premieres
розуміємо, що сьогодні шовкун справі крайньої
таорміни волає пише бібліотеку ми
розпущена йому процедура проводами для
студентів басу йому собою травмата
документики свічу особливо
цього досить ніби цю машину
розуміємо шийки синч документів на раз
вранці це не можете часто він наймає
ніяких фінчер документі 1 грама
допиту дату каматаки після чусова після
отелення універсалу civic і люди на просять
провести себе перевіряючи факт начальників
туди натомість п'ють і не навіть мені латуні базу
випробування святі на піт-стопі телиць
тут мене за руку вони звучали що ми б
ви не також
за сорок тисяч ситуації клапани всі
пройдуть у нього, що ти мені шевченко цьому
у розпорядженні підготовленому в казан
ще зверху вони тут немає в такому разі
навчання в одну студентку групу зберіг
анабель шик я т-т-тут кого сип
процедура буду максимально спрощеною
тут їм просто продажів ранку продовжує
та паспорт забула камер funcom екологи
це не дарма його з випробувань світло і
перевірені факт начальниці люди на цю
тему цю статтю для за рукавами
навіщо нашу за 1 - повторюємо ситуацію
колектив туди намалюю цю масу на пику
нас є сім тисяч say of proper
бачення нас проти 500 коване значення
цінного лика часто в мережі заявляти це
нас над ходу але протистань йому місяць
api 2 ми всі фіксували його крім бази та
за російську процедуру буду
затвор джона всі ці студенти вранці ноги
запрошення стримо щоб за раз просто все
тумен автор атола товарний знак водолаз
даних при якій місите і за раз буду
смогу тут на цій саппоро я найняла
процедура проведення максимально
попиті на і факти ніж трава перед і
продовжує і паспорт помічаємо ще й купу
люди нас з локшини університету року
претендувати вона теж вчаться
університеті шин-чан пробую слову то я
буду за про по теперішньому варіанті
намагатимемося пробувати варіанти в
таких місцях як їх він і джазу раз
перебуваєте алла знав що дехто
всі 166 тисяч проявити університету дуг
і його щось випадково їхню безособову розмістить
а ось вона можна його і
і проростуть уми будуть пропливати про те
числа і не варіантах менших місцях
контрактний а також можете переклади тася
контрактника можете працювати і вся яскрава
тим годин та проведення обидва переклади ти
вся путін на зарплату вже в університеті
лик його на перекладаєте пропадання
контрактники в особі у нас, крім наказ
таким ім'ям сорту але цього можемо на
ремені міністр зі свитою наука
прогулянка фер k-pop тракт на камбузі
ніч основи це наказ поки побігти на
computer запитують одяг це на газ по
контрактника у розпорядженні також
рубльова нині харчування проблем на тому що
студенти донецької та луганської області на
закрила сесії літні та формально на мій
апетит а ось для нарощування ним
стипендій цьому у розпорядженні
пропадаєте таки варіант що їм на
керувати від упаковані на закриту
сесію їм нарахується стипендія за
результатом у зама висоси і так те щоб
вони не стирчали стипендію розвитку
їм буду перебувати стипендія за
результатом у самого соси нас народиться
харчування сусанни тільки викладаються
суїцид вже брати їх противники в
бюджетної сфери та кіпру малює на turbo
сезар основ чудово розуміємо шоу jamming
багато там працюйте обоз пробоєм обидва
закриття all ці люди так само
продовжити вранці у це зарплату там ще
сповідую до кодексу закону України про
партію і всі люди на і можемо вийти на
робочі місця через обставлені ці плями
і на і закласти те і по ви на наркоті
Середня зарплата
так це відчувається на території кого
комірниця asus вулиця притягнути його була
адміністрації треба рівні перед наступництвом
і так далі і так далі, а то ми не можемо
просто підняти доплати ти людям
зарплату тому щоб через ви і
медійні можете виходити на роботу тут
ось абсолютно точну
на сторінках людожер поважається
вигаданих прогулянок та факти що нікого
не на раху-це зарплату
складу, ніж просто тільки складна
ситуація цю зарплату за раз відкинути
всі бюджетні крики процедурні приховує
в області на ці поживанов чудово ви
ходіть на роботу тут у c знайти capacity
to до ситуації з лікарями ти сам їх
живими заразною працюйте та польщі для
нас було про головне харчування штук щоб
за росіян туди анти впарювала кількома
зі ставок в університеті на заклавши
фундамент у студентів action вирізку
скоро uchun куди нам студентів вирізку
скоро джему цегла ставок і людям на
голови чоловікові поглядів та скарбу чіп
дуглас на росія затворниця тільки
процедура там же слова 1 до неї щоб
фактично контент на разин з меншого
ти призначив атаки річки ставок і вона
ніби ви машинам з діамантових ладу
chef today тільки тисяч лялька дачі річки
витрачати робота і буде через суботу і
змивання повна обидва поповнювати ряди
вимушених переселенців та захищати
дорош гри для бюджету у нас правте обидва
стрибати на нічий бік розумний і типу
літаючі на світ came to me у нас
справжні терези раз і радували вас
пекарі про студента ви його вночі з умикну
тієї ситуації соціального збори мене 42
кладу чого університеті
свердлі інших піді інших двох
відео 2 дні ви краще вийти ці плани
будуть змінюватися то тут встала на
замажемо
нашого спливу випадково тату на розвиненому
руйнується варіантів знаєш тицятися
тусується знайти річка us with мені своє
сосу суеца всіх бюджетний 9 ранку
монтування через казначейство
річкам зарости простіше вона керувала
практично не виплачувати цю машину
казначейства саблукова на це вдасться
прості казначейства
менше місця
вишивається на рази але лікарі буду
маріуполь ще раз на тиждень у принципі
наскільки я розумію прямо беру слова
дуже мужик Росії знаючи а там план його
лассо дроту не казначейства вінчі
місця і таким чином тут його то
виплата нарощуванням нора холу цілий
факти але на короткий час на копачі
пергаміну рахова юца